küssen ist toll aber warum eigentlich
unsere lipp gehören zu den
empfindlichsten teilen unseres körpers
sie haben sogar eine höhere nerven
dichte als unser genitalbereichs küssen
senden diese nervensignalen unser gehirn
oder eine regelrechte hormone partie in
unserem belohnungssystem gefeiert wird
tanz der moleküle
wir stellen euch die botenstoffe vor die
küssen so schön machen
erster oxytocin auch bekannt als das
kuschelhormon stärke zwischen
menschliche bindungen
es ist dasselbe hormon das auch bei
mutter und kind während des stillens
ausgeschüttet wird
zweitens otto familien wird bei allem
ausgeschüttet was uns spaß macht wie wir
teilweise ähnlich wie kokain
suchtpotenzial und einnahme einmaleffekt
mit eingeschlossen
drittens serotonin dopamin bekannt als
glückshormon ein mangel an serotonin
steht in verbindung mit
depressionskrankheiten adrenalin sorgt
für den achterbahn mäßigen rauscht der
kurs steigt die pupillen weiten sich
schließen wir deswegen vielleicht die
augen beim küssen von endorphinen das
sind rapide die für gefühle der euphorie
sorgen
der name endorphin kommt von ingo humor
viel was so viel heißt wie körpereigene
morphin das berühmte schmerzmittel
priester euro schmerzen weg langfristig
sind küssen außerdem die produktion des
stresshormons cortisol
regelmäßiges knutschen entspannt also
kennt ihr schon unser letztes video zum
küssen
teil 1 gibt es hier oder unter dem link
in der beschreibung